oh okay
all right for those joining this live
stream we are looking at error handling
a multi-language
as one of a series of meetings
dealing with this issue okay connor can
you remind us where we got to last time
so
yeah so um we're talking about error
handling and in particular we're talking
about
um at least in in the first phase of
this project uh error handling in sort
of development projects um so not you
know error they're you know held down in
package code um you know for developers
who are being careful about how they do
errors um we did talk a bit last time
and we'll perhaps get it into this this
time about um adding error handling to
sort of code that doesn't have a lot of
existing error handling infrastructure
um but that's
we're more going to be focused on on the
developer use case of people who want to
handle their errors in a careful and
deliberate way
how can we help them along with that and
in particular work the context is we're
thinking about how a lot of internal
projects uh do error handling right now
in
ways that are kind of have a lot of
duplication of effort
so we talked a bit last time about some
concrete ideas about new functions
related to error tagging
changes to our failure representation
how those are created
and then functions for for kind of
raising or throwing failures and and
then catching them and handling them in
a more programmatic and more ergonomic
way
um
some of the things that we started to
get into
hold on so what we're not talking about
and what is a future discussion is
you've got a wfr function
and
you've written it to follow the code
path you immediately could think of
but there is an error code path and we
need to have a
nice clean way to
you know deal with
oh this function was supposed to return
a number and it's not
make that an error path type thing
um
and but that's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about a
different thing of crunchier
larger scale
industrial type development well i i
would argue that the phase i don't know
how this has been reorganized now but
the phase four stuff i think would would
maybe also include that right that
basically if you're
if you have certain built-in functions
or some mechanism for having built-in
functions there are exceptions of this
kind then it that also sort of often
handles
you know this sort of automatic error
path
and if you just add one handle to the
outside of the function
but yeah yeah what you mean you mean
this is the function
this function usually returns numbers
tag it that way
no i mean i mean more i mean more of
like i think that usually where where
you know naive functions go wrong is not
that you know oh it returned a string
instead of a number and you know what a
surprise it's usually that some function
in the middle returns a string instead
of a number
and it's a cascade of problems but then
of course you know whatever function if
if something returns a string instead of
a a number and then the next thing is
you know call to to you know i don't
know dot or something and dot freaks out
because you gave it a string then then
well that's that example because that
wouldn't but yes okay fine fine well
well uh
not dot you know net train you give it a
a an integer you know it's a single
argument and it freaks out then then uh
if i mean this is sort of the issue if
you imagine that net train through an
exception or through some sort of easily
catchable thing i mean maybe just like a
message
then um which it does then you can you
can handle that
so
yeah
and just to be maybe to frame that a bit
so because there are related questions
um one of the things that i've
put on this this kind of summary of the
meeting that we want to talk about is
his categorization of messages um
you know we originally thinking about
this mostly in terms of you know suppose
you had a function like somebody wrote a
piece of code like this right the
careful programmer would write this if
statement before they go ahead and do
read string right they're going to check
for this potential failure condition and
they're going to raise their own error
code to indicate what went wrong that
maybe the less careful or the you know
the person who's still kind of in the
prototyping phase they're just gonna
call read string without checking um and
read string will issue a message if this
file doesn't exist
and
by you know by having a mechanism by
which
we can
uh con you know convert messages into
errors
at the time they occur you know stop the
kind of cascade of unevaluated you know
whatever failures before it starts
um
we we can add robustness to code that
wasn't written with this explicit error
handling um by by having this outer
handle that would catch you know would
uh check for those messages and kind of
transfer control flow at that as i've
said many times i strongly believe that
we should have messages that are off by
default
that can be checked this way
yeah i think this
yeah go ahead
and i think that's something we're
thinking about i mean obviously it's a
hairy problem but um
certainly that's something that will be
easier to speak about in a concrete way
like i have a message it's off by
default but in a particular situation i
might want to handle it and opt in for a
particular scope say
um
but by the way has anyone done the
actual benchmarking to know if off by
default messages have a performance
impact
i mean like of course if they're only
happening on like kind of expensive
operations like packing and unpacking a
packed array i mean then that's kind of
okay but if they're happening on cheap
operations yeah well we need to check
that then there may need to be some new
mechanism to deal with off by default
messages
yes that's a reasonable question
um
yeah
okay but so your basic design here is
this handle function
that kind of cleans up afterwards saying
if there was a message
then
do something is that correct
uh just to be clear that we're on the
same page so handle is sort of like
check and that it it it
well maybe okay let me say this a
different way handle of a message if you
if you write in some the syntax is rough
so we're just going to speak roughly for
now but if you have something like a
rule that handles a particular message
in your handle it will transfer control
flow it it'll it'll stop executing at
the point that that message is uh
issued or use is is raised and transfer
control flow to the handler and it won't
go back to the code that message came
from
um
so it's a way that you know the message
quiet right it's uh
yeah
yeah
what's the difference between this and
confirm quiet
well it handles
various things that are not just
messages
right yes what is the idea of what
happened so handle those
yes no no confirm
no right right but confirm quiet only so
right confirmed quiet first of all only
detects messages as opposed to other
things and second confirm quiet is
really for use
right like if you have an enclosed
it's okay there's two things you can
write with confirm quiet
um
the sort of intended use
uh is you do enclose and then you're in
the middle of your code you make a call
and you know this call is a little
sketchy so you say confirm quiet around
just that call and basically if if that
call fails then it you know then it will
detect it but what a lot of people end
up doing because this is kind of similar
anyway is you're just doing close of
confirmed quiet and then all your code
goes inside of the confirmed quiet and
really this should be a separate
function you know i mean really this is
the thing that check would like to be
maybe um but because check isn't that
then you can get around it by using
confirm quiet
sorry say again what you need
the case that you need
the case you're just saying close if
confirmed quiet of blah where blah is a
giant piece of code
and this is basically check that that
fails immediately when a message is
thrown okay which is the same as
connor's handle thing correct yes yes
well it's a subset of the handle thing
what else did the handle do
yes i think that the main point is when
i suggested this handle function is that
it should be
i mean it's its primary purpose would be
to handle exceptions that were raised
but since we have a lot of different
things that catch things not others
i thought that maybe we can have
something that can be used to
act on any thing
that happens and that would be messages
turned into exceptions or even abort can
be handled that way or arbitrary signals
or memory memory exceptions whatever so
it's intended as a
kind of new
catch-all
thing that can be highly configured
and the list of handlers declares which
ones it actually acts upon
okay
i also think that there is a way to
add this picture
in that
in addition to considering handle as a
kind of final stop of your journey of
your various signals like exceptions or
boards you can also think of it as a
sort of a transformer
which in general can transform one type
of signal into the other
so i find it personally more useful to
think of handle as a transformer
with of course 90 percent of its
functionality being used mostly as a
final stop where you catch everything
but you don't have to think of it this
way
but i mean confirming close is also a
transformer in that sense in that things
are getting turned into failure objects
is that right
yes but the more a more narrow type of
transformer than handle is supposed to
be
it's the difference between closing
so the difference in this and in closing
confirm is that i mean it is less about
uh
i i think it's more about about like the
sort of uh
it's more about the sort of usage right
confirm and close again is more like
optionals where you're just sort of uh
you you're basically just saying if you
put uh if you put a failure into my
block of code here it's going to spit
another failure out
right and of course
if you throw an error some sort of error
into my little block of code it's going
to throw another error out the other
side this is more about
generalized uh you know generalized
exception throwing and catching
and and one of the things that it does
is it detects you know messages and
aborts which is
yeah which which happens to coincide
with what what confirmed the close also
can do right right so if i can just
offer my experience of recently using
confirm and close right so you know i
you know so in sort of the my main
input processing
down value that i wrote
right basically the most of it is inside
of a single confirm
and sorry you can single and close and
then like this thing which i know can
issue a message but otherwise it's fine
isn't it confirmed quiet and this thing
had better return
you know a list of two things or i'm i'm
dead so that's in a
uh confirm
uh etc etc and i could have done all of
that before and what i would have done
is i would have had a big catch and then
every other line would have been if
bad thing happened throw error and
instead now i just have confirm
i haven't closed and then confirm block
confirm block confirm block
and and it's you know sort of automated
that workflow
you know handle is sort of trying to be
more general than that
all right and there is one more thing
very important to mention about handle
we plan handle to be very tightly
integrated with the exception system
that we plan to introduce
and that will simplify things and make
them more robust for those who use
exceptions
okay let me make a separate point which
is probably for aubry i don't think
brenton in the code assistance project
has thought about
uh code suggestions that involve adding
confirms
but that seems a useful thing to do
that is it would be nice to have a a uh
you know code assistance that you can
run on a wfr that will suggest where you
might put
you know confirms
does that make sense
yeah i can i can discuss that with him
for sure
okay all right
so let's go back
okay connor where did you want to go
next i mean you're talking about handle
and i think i we understand roughly what
the concept of handle is
yeah um and we're we're
i mean in our in our
again our rough agenda for this meeting
we weren't really hoping to get deep
into handle because it's
it's a hairy problem and we'll have time
in the future to go more more into that
um but you know we're talking about
categorization of messages which as i
was saying earlier is
um
you know our long term our vision is
that
raise and handle are going to be
you know a programmer's first tools that
they reach for in their toolbox for
doing error handling now obviously for
practical reasons we have a lot of
functions that issue messages so we need
to be able to deal with messages in a
coherent and robust way um and and to do
that we need
uh
you know something like handle that lets
us respond to individual messages um
but also hopefully some some level of
automation you know some level of
categorization of
you know this message
always rep you know if this message
always represents a failure we don't
want people who are trying to write
robust code to have to you know repeat
you know every time somebody writes a
piece of code we don't want them to have
to spell out their own list of specific
messages all right can you un on can you
move that notebook the untitled notebook
out of the way slightly yeah sorry about
that okay so your proposal is that
instead of
the raise thing
is the modern version of a message in
the sense that it
simply
raises this
exception-like thing without necessarily
printing anything
correct it's control flow
yeah
yeah
yeah that's correct
okay yeah
um
and handle is the thing that that
obviously handles when something goes
wrong and it's first the primary thing
primary thing it's going to handle are
things that have been raised um but we
again it needs to handle messages as
well since there's just so many
functions that issue messages um
and and we were discussing a bit in our
prep meeting this morning and we're
hoping to get into this today a bit
about these questions around
how do we
provide a level of automation
um so that you know if there's a mess i
mean we're going into some examples let
me just yeah okay but i've got a
question i mean sure in the current
world in the world of the future you
think
that user code will generate razors
as opposed to user code you know could
generate messages too
um
but are you imagining a future world in
which
system functions also generate razors
so that's
uh yeah probably the most controversial
yeah that's that's got to be the most
controversial thing in here and and
we're we're
pushing that to what was previously
phase three and is now phase four where
you know because that's kind of a
question of convention right is it our
convention that
uh public functions you know system
functions or top level functions and
non-system packages
can they be allowed to leak uncaught
raises out outside of themselves
and we obviously don't have that
convention now
there is a desire to have that
convention but
there are
okay so
there are different okay but i mean so
but the point might be you know the
message mechanism is 35 years old
and it does quite well
but it is also very
human oriented
that is it's intended you know
generating a message that a human will
read
right the idea of automatically handling
messages was not really something
heavily imagined when the messages
system was built
okay so an alternative way to get there
from here would be to say that system
functions which generate messages
that we would basically do a curation
pass going through and saying well that
that function generates a message but it
also should generate a raise and the
raises will be like more computable
messages basically
because messages are not very computable
and that's what we're about to discuss
right in other words
a message you know one could imagine a
situation in which a message generates
an association that is has all kinds of
categorized things about how important
it is and what kind of you know this
that and the other rather than just
saying you know the cat is out of the
bag in words for a human to read
yeah
yeah and that's exactly part of the
problem and the other part is that
messages typically do not stop
evaluation they continue
and exceptions will alter that part as
well
right so which i think is good
right but i mean it could be the case
that what we want to do
is the following thing every single
place in our internal code where we
generate a message
have that same piece of code generate a
raise
but that raise
would be a computable message in which
over time we have an association that is
associated with every you know
message exceptionally type thing that
contains
data slash metadata
that is filterable by handle in some
organized way
of course the consequences of this is
that any time you
uh
you know
have a message evaluation will stop so
and i remember oh no no no no no no yes
that that is exactly what it means to do
a raise okay but fine but then then we
need some version of arrays we need some
version of it so that it generates the
metadata for a raise but the question of
whether that raise is going to be fatal
or not needs to be handled by the
outside handler
uh no but
it i has uh raised here uh
is that
the current uh the way we currently
think of exception mechanism and the
rays is that it immediately stops any
further i know i know but i think that's
wrong okay so i think what should happen
is just like the rays should it should
have an association that have all has
all kinds of things in it like is this a
type of ex of exception that will
guarantee to give a wrong answer or is
it one that just affects the precision
of the answer is this a you know i don't
know what you know let's say there are
20
signals 20 attributes of every raise
one of those attributes is
this is fatal you've got to stop here
whenever this raise is generated stop
here
or another setting of that attribute
would be um it depends this might or
might not be fatal
you you can if you wrap
a handle around this
all the razors inside that have certain
metadata would become
fatal
so the thing is though i don't know what
this i mean i don't think this
that's a fine thing to do but it doesn't
solve the the problem which is that i
mean you'd still have uh
you know
for example if i call transpose on on a
non-rectangular array presumably that's
a that's an exception right that that
that's what we're saying right now that
they'll call a raise and it's also
raised where it's guaranteed to give the
wrong answer yep um
but so what's it says so is the idea
that okay there it's going to throw an
exception that's going to change the
control flow because that's a big you
know that's no i'm saying that what
should happen right i'm saying what
should happen is if that is enclosed
in a handle
right okay so so this is this is related
to the idea okay so so basically this is
this is related to the idea that we had
a while ago
of
you know they're basically are are
raises but they're off by default and
there's some wrapper or variable you can
set that basically activates the raises
and maybe
with the baby handle is the thing that
that also activates them yes and i think
it's useful in some pieces of code to
allow for raises i mean this is one of
the other points here i mean this is
sort of a phase four thing that it may
be useful in some code to allow for you
know at least an interactive coding to
allow for raises to go to the top
and to make that sort of look nice and
something yeah i i agree where it comes
up with an answer but the answer comes
with a disclaimer basically
no no i mean i mean i mean like like you
call raise
i mean it
like an interactive code maybe you can
have a function that that fails and you
just want to say when this fails i want
you just to completely you know fail all
the way to the top
i see and so rather than just having it
bro right rather than just a rather
silly uncle throw message it comes out
with a nice you know
pinkened box or something
yes yes i mean we have part of of that
right here on the lower left on the
screen i mean
currently the idea is that messages
would continue to work as they are but
if you mention a message inside handle
just as you mentioned it inside confirm
client
it would turn that message into
an exception that is then wasted and
handled by this way yeah right right now
the other idea of having raises that
could somehow be turned on or off
i'm not sure i mean we had this last
time that if if i have a piece of code i
test for an error condition and if the
error condition is
present i generate an exception then i
should be guaranteed that the rest of my
code
is not run under this error condition
otherwise i would have to test again and
so on so okay hold on hold on hold on to
me this is deeply connected to this
categorization messages question
because i can imagine a case where uh
you know where our messages slash razors
are curated to have a computable version
of the message that has a bunch of
attributes and you say
anytime
there's a message of this type
um
you know with this attribute generated
then break the control flow right so
this is the question is though that if
we allow some exceptions to break the
control flow
then then how does this i mean like okay
option one is is exceptions always break
the control flow that when you call
raise it's always going to
to you know immediately raise etc etc
and and we're saying well there's some
situations where you might not want that
or something
but then the issue is that
or there's some situations where where
it's two it's too uh you know different
from current behavior et cetera if
raised throws an exception oh but then
there are also other situations where
yes rey should throw an exception that
sort of you know breaks control flow and
so on
and so it's sort of like you know if the
issue is that it's it's it's we you know
we can't have exceptions that break
control flow but sometimes we can i
don't know hold on
can i
try to jump in here i mean so okay
from the developer perspective and i
think this is a very important thing the
function called raise
uh
should be consistent in how it behaves
and it should be reliable that it it
begins
right right right and i was thinking why
we're talking we need advise right this
would be the computational alternative
to messages you know where we'd have
something like yeah that's a nice name
but it's fine it's soft raised basically
right so like uh
um
the wrong button okay
we would have advise
which
is not raised but could trigger control
flow if something is listening listening
to that you know thing has been advised
yeah so like advise um
what was one of the uh
one of the examples um
transpose has gone wonky transpose has
gone wonky and this would be
computational you know you could imagine
there's something in here that that adds
you know could have a stack trace it
could have uh but much more importantly
it has a computable version of the
message because messages i you know just
to remember the history messages were
designed to be read by humans that was
their only consumer 35 years ago
yeah okay then we added you know check
was an attempt to have a computational
consumer of messages that's pretty weak
and confirm quiet as the next
level of computational cons consumption
of messages
well we also have message object for
transferring messages between kernels
right
i mean roman can correct me but i
believe that's how messages are
transferred between
parallel kernels
well no i mean that that just happens on
the level of the
the master income communication i mean
message generates a message
a message packet which i then just
forward to the to the front end
i mean i'm not concerned about messages
on the on the remote kernels but
anything other than anything
any non uh right normal control flow
needs to be caught on the remote end so
that it doesn't escape
right
we do have other things that don't use
wsdp like amazon what is that remote
batch
evaluate
yeah but that's that's bad that's not
interactive so that okay that that would
be one case where messages are not for
human consumption right
for which which case
well if you want something in batch mode
like remo patch submit or so i know but
i don't think we have very good handling
i mean i think we are basically saying
you know a look check from like 30 years
ago or more is is basically a thing
which attempts by name of message
although it's never worked very well
and then we tried to have buckets of
messages and that never worked very well
and that's i think what we're what we're
so i mean just to summarize roughly here
people are saying raise has to be a
deterministic thing fine given that name
you know names are still subject to
change advise is the you can take the
advice or you cannot take the advice
okay yeah
and and as a programmer importantly
you would understand that if you do this
this has no effect no no
it's not going to
have an effective control flow yeah
right you ought to have alternative
control flow handling um if you if you
care about the control flow as opposed
to just oh by the way for certain uses
this might be a horrible thing
right because you as a programmer might
be saying look the case where this
becomes a null list or something is like
well you know if it happens if they
specified that then they get what they
asked for but then it could be the case
that at the outside you say oh my gosh
if it becomes a null list you know we're
dead and so we've got to protect against
that
can you remind me what create error type
and create failure are
okay uh
so create error type
it register you give it a symbol you
give it a set of kind of
parent error tags that this will expand
into
create error type is directly related to
create failure
let me just show the example this is
probably the quickest way so you give
create failure a tag that you've
registered using create error type and
it spits out a failure object um that
has the
parents that were associated with that
error type and the metadata you provide
so it's a way it's a lightweight way to
add
something like inheritance to failures
so that a file error is an instance of
an i o error
okay
that's by the way how you would uh if
you had some distinction about fatal
errors which i'm not sure is ever
possible to do but if it is possible to
do then i think that's how you do it but
i i claim that what we really want is
some very elaborate multiple inheritance
thing because i claim that there are 20
different signals or attributes that
there might exist for a message it isn't
just i mean conceivably there are
families that simply inherit from others
but i think the more relevant thing is
that there are properties attributes
whatever of different messages and i
think that's what we wanted to talk
about before with categorization of
messages
let's let's explore that question if we
could so so this is really
the create i'm sorry i forget what it's
called the create uh error
yeah so that does allow multiple
inheritance does it not yes it does it
should yeah but actually i wanted to
comment on what steven just said
i'm i think that the question of
inheritance between these area types
which are new errors
and the question about categorization
and elaborate categorization of messages
they are very related but it would be
best if we still treat them somewhat
separately
in that uh the error the the error
system that we're uh suggesting
is supposed to be for you know when
people just throw a certain kind of
errors and for the messages we may need
something actually way more elaborate if
we want to categorize them so
i will
yeah but you know i think that the main
issue here is
there's a transitional phase so first
thing is we support for user code
uh sort of computable messages
then we have a separate project that
gradually starts to make messages
in
because you know what's it gonna
actually look like what it's going to
look like is
we've had message documentation for 30
something years
for some messages i don't know how well
that's been maintained
because it's not clear people really
care that much about it
okay the idea here would be
that in the end if we have computable
messages that in a function like
transpose there will be a section of the
documentation which simply lists
all of the raises that can happen all of
the
advisors whatever that can happen inside
transpose
yeah there is no question about it the
question is whether the part of our
suggestion regarding error types can be
developed and employed in the uh i don't
know
yeah like whether whether they can be
fully orthogonal or one strongly depends
on the other oh
yeah go ahead yeah my uh our opinion i
think i can speak for many of us in the
uh arahanna group is that we tried to
structure things to be fully resolute to
each other in other words
discussing this error types at least the
general framework for error types right
now
will not prevent us from in parallel or
later uh categorizing messages with some
elaborate scheme that's making this
mapping that's fine but i think we've
already got i mean how many messages are
there in the system five thousand ten
thousand messages of that order anybody
know
it's of that order okay
we've that already gives us a lot of
data on what kinds of things we're going
to need to categorize
so even though we may not get to it
immediately but i think the way the way
to think about this is gradually in
version 14 15 whatever
um gradually functions will start
getting it reminds me so much of these
horrible fortran
documentation things
a list of
possible
sort of error conditions
that they can generate absolutely okay
which we haven't had in the past
um
and you know some of those conditions
will be things that some people might
say isn't really an error like it could
be
oh
this inverse is ill-conditioned
well some people might say well so what
or another thing would be this inverse
here's a good example
um
this is a good example let's say these
eigenvalues are degenerate
okay to many people that is not an error
it's just the way it is
but to some people that might be an oh
my gosh if they're degenerate the rocket
is going to blow up type thing
okay
and you might say well check whether to
generate separately but maybe this isn't
the best of examples but i can imagine a
case where that is a completely it's a
piece of advice
by the way these these eigenvalues were
degenerate
okay so it generates an advice
but it doesn't generate
uh you know that wouldn't even raise the
level of being an error in the sense
that we've had them previously
it's kind of like an off by default
message type thing
yeah but just more computable yeah yes
but i mean but it means that there's
something funky that happened
and even though we wouldn't have made
that
even a message
it's it's it's not dramatic enough to
even be a message
um
you know
that's the thing which could be listed
in the documentation as one of the
things that can happen with dysfunction
yeah absolutely
yeah sure sure that's a great idea
absolutely i i'm just saying it's
somewhat uh
it's a
somewhat separate topic which we can
obviously go into it's just that we have
an awful lot of data because we can have
a lot of theories about what messages
you know what
what kinds of exceptions and so on are
going to be relevant in user code but we
already have 10 000 examples or whatever
it is
right so we should be looking at those
because those are ten thousand examples
of pseudo
that didn't happen to be user code but
it could have been type thing
so okay let's go back on to
categorization of messages if we
sure um just i'm gonna make a note about
what you just said
um
okay sorry uh so message the
categorization of messages um
but did you want to lead in with a
question
well i want to i want to start talking
about that i mean the
okay so first point is i'm pretty sure
that there are 20 attributes
okay i think the idea to reduce it to
like three is wrong
let's start listing what some of those
attributes might be
so potential attributes of
advisements perhaps
yes right
right sorry it's an attribute like a
field an association a field in an
association
no it's a field and an association
potential properties we could say
right well there's definitely i would
imagine that that's unbounded
but yeah the question are are there
properties that are
no but that's not unbounded it's
important that it's standardized because
the handling of these things
is
you know
it's like it is
this is an interesting point okay how
unbounded should it be
right because
most code is going to say
okay if it is a severity level above two
you know if we had severity levels which
i do not recommend but if we had that
we would say if it's severity above two
error out otherwise don't
look i mean i think the thing is it's a
unhappy code is unhappy in many
different ways i mean if you have like
pretty much every if you look at
messages you know right if you look at
messages and you look at what parameters
each message takes right which is sort
of a proxy for these attributes
they take lots of different things
because it'll be something like oh it's
a file io error okay maybe all file i o
errors should include uh the path to the
file that you're struggling with
fine but but but then but then there are
things like
you know oh it's a compilation error and
you know they're they're they're
they're 500 different ways the
compilation could fail i mean oh the
function that you tried to call doesn't
exist okay you give the function you
tried to call you know as as an
attribute oh you know the the type
signature the function you tried to call
is wrong oh you know there's so many
different things
so look there's an empirical thing we
can do which is let's take all the
messages in the system and let's look at
this question that you asked what
parameters they take
and probably not just all parameters
they take but all parameters we would
like to provide to them in principle if
we redo this
well yeah but i mean
but the thing that christopher is
pointing out is that
that there's already
um
what i'd imagine is that there's a small
number of these error classes
like that there are okay there's a maybe
relatively small number of these error
classes like there may be there are 20
core ones
uh and
and which have standardized attributes
so all children of that class have to
provide
you know all children of the file i
arrow error class have to provide the
path or something like that right there
may be like 20 of those then there's
probably
uh maybe these aren't documented but
there's probably one of these for each
packlet like for every package will have
its own general error for its its world
and then below that they're probably you
know
the actual number of errors as opposed
to error classes is probably
so
huge
probably have like 20 things at the top
and then they're all very high degree
and there's a billion things underneath
the leaves
well this is exactly what we need to do
okay so look who can do do we have
access let's see there used to be
actual documentation there used to be a
little booklet which was a collection of
errors it was created by dave withoff
um do we still have that do anybody know
um
there's probably there might be a guide
page for all the message documentation
i don't think that's for sure there used
to be
an actual um
yeah
i don't think well try searching any of
these involving messages
yeah
let's just guide
one is the messages tech note warning's
a must just tech note that was the one
okay
let's oh no
well okay
it might be
i mean i think have a copy of it
somewhere we we have this little book
which is you know hundreds and hundreds
of messages
well all right all you know all properly
written messages are in one file which
is i can tell you how long it is it's
probably seven thousand lines long okay
where is that five to ten thousand what
what file is that
that's error message.m
where in the kernel i'm just looking for
it so i can open it up
well i think it's in its own repo isn't
it yes
oh you know i mean if if you want the
one that's in the layout then it's in
understand error messages that what that
workflow at the bottom that might
contain information
under so okay
right so i think these are all just yeah
okay so i need to subtract off three
lines for the initial cost there are
currently exactly 8 500 messages in
error message.n wow i was pretty good at
my five to ten thousand
is that a good estimate or are there
more impactlets they're more impacts
although those are generally not
localized on the order of ten thousand
yeah
okay so what we need to do is start
breaking these down into buckets
where is that file i just want to pull
it up
in the layout or in source
anywhere that i can find it most quickly
it's it's i believe it's messages.m in
content system files kernel
i believe
text resources messages
uh
one thing i wanted to mention is that
those buckets may
not necessarily be disjoined
buckets of messages that you stephen
planned to put those messages of course
they weren't distracted that's why i'm
saying they aren't buckets
yeah it was a bucket they're just
properties
yeah it's not buckets it's properties
yeah and they will actually they they
could potentially map quite nicely into
error types that we are defining in this
error system with multiple inheritance
so that that's where i don't believe in
types in this regard i just don't
believe in it i think that this is
okay
well the type is mostly just attack
i know but so what we need to do is take
this list okay and again please let's
find the old
uh
booklet about messages which describe
you know have a paragraph i think they
even have examples for a bunch of these
messages
okay let's get a scene do you have any
see we have any keywords that i should
use if i'm looking for that i mean book
of messages but i you know what i have a
copy of it someplace i just have to find
one
i'm sure you do right it's the finding
at this time
well no i i i mean i i just re
rearranged all of my wolfram language
books because they had overflown
overflowed um wait do you mean a
physical book
a message i mean a physical book
okay yeah we we used to actually sell
like
you know
a lot of a lot of the things that are
that are now like the longer like
monographs or like tutorial collections
those used to be sold as physical
books you could purchase
yeah for version six
yeah that that i knew i'm just surprised
that there was a dedicated book of just
messages
i did not know that either that that is
a little bit surprising but it does seem
like a very david widow sort of thing to
do so
on that level uh again given that the
author cited i'm not i'm not shocked
that this thing exists
yeah it's a very no fun book you know
you want to see the book of all the cool
functionality this is all the book of
pain and failures
right why are there messages for private
symbols in here
oh
um
probably no they're they're aliased
yeah see it's right it's also orthogonal
oh yeah i see okay yes yes
i mean this list itself is something
that we should
there's probably a lot of things that
could be combined into into
uh more general messages with more
parameters wait a minute did you stop
sharing connor no
now i do want to say
so we've i mean i just put these random
strings in here but i i think
to me at least it seems obvious that
this would because we're talking about
doing this programmatically this would
be a tag
like we're using with create failure
um
and potentially that even means
rather than create error type you might
have a more generic you know create tag
or something um and i think that that i
mean this system already supports
it it's not a strict type hierarchy
right it's just a collection of loose
tags you can have multiple of
guys guys i'm telling you what's going
to happen which you're going to discover
as you start looking at these actual
messages okay because these messages are
a proxy for exceptions
okay
okay
by the way i looked for this book i
don't seem to have it but immediately at
hand it is a purple and white book of
the same series that we had things like
guide to standard add-on packages
um and if all else fails
um dave withoff would be able to find it
because he wrote it
okay
um
i have it i've got it right here
oh but it's a title from from
mathematics to 2.1
okay okay
what is the title todd
it says mathematica i just put it away
mathematical warning messages it says
technical report mathematical messages
how thick is it how many pages
let's see
it's you know it's like a third of an
inch um
it's 350 pages
wow
i i presume there's more than just the
message text there's no there isn't that
yeah there's explanations
yeah but it but it's it's it's you know
it's it's just the lags and the messages
apply to them
that'd be funny if it's in if it's in um
if it's been scanned
wow
really
well maybe we can find it from there
anyway we we can clearly get this
there's clearly an online version of it
i mean there's clearly we
i'm sure worst case you know someone in
champaign can go to the fifth floor and
pull it off of a bookshelf yes uh i i
i'm
actually not in champaign today but uh i
i i was gonna offer my services as
somebody who can actually go into the
library and find physical books
yeah
um no
right we do we do a wrap up and i see
steven you want to make a comment about
categorization and types yeah i think i
think there's a very important exercise
to be done which is to go look at
these um
uh
sorry what is what is this thing called
it's called mathematical warnings and
messages is that right mathematica
warning messages parentheses technical
report that's what it seems like
um hold on one second and see if i can
pull this up
um
i have the version 2.3 development plan
which contained enhancing that um
we should make sure that gets back on
the agenda
yes um
my god
this is kind of interesting actually
this has the do you have it should i
share or you want to share uh
well i could hear i can just send it to
you hold on one second
um
let me see i could just send you a
message here
i need to go in a second here but i just
want to
oh come on
well actually it wasn't as easy to do
this
never mind well okay here let me let me
just chair for a second here
right
here
version 2.3 development plan
uh
my gosh look at that one huh
well that's back on the edge
look at this implement special data
structures for numerical matrices we
just we just are doing this now in 13.1
extend the compiler to handle lists and
compressed matrices
uh okay
well that's basically done
yes
maybe we should just you know
just just add a you know
add add uh just make it you know this is
the 14 uh
you know 13.3
all right get a little bit of white out
be good snail right
update this okay
um i'm sure i have this in in my
some place in my archives that's what i
think
it's very likely
um
my gosh i have a
um
well anyway i mean i'm pretty sure i can
find this
we're sure it really is called you
physically have it in front of you todd
yeah it's called mathematical warning
messages
it's a technical report at the top
this is the blue before we went to
purple this is the blue version oh it's
a blue version before purple
um
i just want to mention briefly i know
stephen you're gonna have to go in a
minute um but if other people could stay
back there's one last thing i want to
talk to people about that's not relevant
to this meeting
um
okay
well uh here you can you can reach out
connor sure um
okay but i think the next important
thing is to go through and start looking
at how would we classify you know what
attributes what properties do we want to
identify in these messages
right
okay because that's go ahead yeah yeah
another question is i mean there
obviously messages that we consider
fatal like wrong number of arguments or
so so if we look at code then probably
there would be always be an if statement
following one of these
things that check for certain error
conditions yeah except most people don't
check that's the problem that's that's
what we're dealing with so i mean i
think categorizing if we've got 10 000
messages we'll probably be able to have
i mean some of them are our generic
general colon colon messages
um
you know this is a this is a project to
do i mean this is you know making
messages computable we've made many
other things computable we'll manage to
make these computable and then we'll be
able to you know make do logic based on
those messages and i need to run
um
so uh
i think we need to end this um uh
um
well we can you can we should probably
say goodbye to our live stream
participants and
continue this another time
okay i'm going to